she's already in the bathroom heating
the sink
he and the sink over here hi I'm Deanna
your friendly neighborhood wine mom and
if you're anything like me you believe
that a glass of wine at 8:00 p.m. makes
you a better mom it's pour yourself
glass because today we have an extremely
special guest you might recognize her
from It's Always Sunny in Philadelphia
please welcome Kaitlin Olson hi did you
say eight o'clock I'm more of a four
o'clock
kind of uh you know get it going kind of
lady you know I agree that we say eight
because it's a little safe oh it is I'm
sorry I'm sorry just kidding I only
start drinking at 8:00 when my kids
aren't dead so I hope you like wine
we're gonna have a little glass I sure
do and you have two kids I do I have two
little boys - boys and you have too many
boys we both have two boys how is that
for you
cheers Cheers uh yeah what's crazy yeah
I don't my first son was not interested
in having another little baby in the
house so for three years it was no get
him off your boob and out of our house
so you have two boys yes we want to see
what it's like if you actually had two
girls okay and kind of going to
impregnate me with twins I wanted to but
the time constraint yeah with this video
they shot me they don't have like a ten
month gestation period yeah so this
challenge is gonna give you a little
glimpse into your future if you had two
girls oh the future like older girls
teenage Oh work okay okay are you ready
no oh hey I'm bringing the wine don't
worry these so we're here in the
BuzzFeed house yeah you have two angelic
sleeping teenage daughter you're lying
to me in this room right behind you your
tasks wake them up yeah make sure
they're dressed okay make their lunch
uh-huh get out the door I'm sure she
meant I'm gonna be here for moral
support
I bet are you ready hmm let's go yeah
okay
cheers Cheers have fun yeah here
oh boy
good morning sleepyheads
hi up and Adam hi oh um yeah yeah yeah
yeah
time to get up time to get up I'm gonna
get my white listen get dressed
looks like you're already wearing your
clothes I like that I like that you get
dressed the night before for school very
smart put some pants on love the shirt
let's go let's go troops let's do it
start yeah honey brush your teeth I
press these mountain coral oh I want to
use something how many minutes do I have
hey it's already in the bathroom I see
always goes in the bathroom here sink
pee in the sink over here we got this oh
you know what I decided
sort of a make your own kind of build
your own sandwich day here we go mom get
all the ingredients in here for you yeah
what you want to make sure she's getting
dressed I think hey get your clothes on
right and I love you guys where's my gym
clothes it doesn't matter to me what
your where I don't even care what you
look like I just want you out of town
you wash them I don't know where they
are
yeah you catching a school bus or what
what's your deal I need to find my gym
clothes I don't know where they are your
gym club yeah not to know what he's not
mine did that belong to you hold on I'm
gonna slap you in the face but not in
front of the cameras this kidding kids
is not okay
pretty good okay get out Oh get out of
here ya know it's not just she said wear
your skirt today she's gonna wear your
skirt today here we go okay what's this
that's my breast that's my dress guess
what I got an idea you're gonna go in
shorts turn around put that on I don't
care then maybe you should maybe I
should have followed the directions okay
my backpack well how am I supposed to
keep track of whose backpack ensued yeah
yeah yeah we should do it's reaching me
you free now yeah no no no it's a
build-your-own sandwich day wallet nope
not that Tommy's that's mommy's I don't
know where you got that okay not gonna
eat this here you go here's a shoe I
don't care
Frogg the garbage can go hungry I have a
great day at least this is so much who's
outside oh you're gonna catch the the
bustle pickup down the street by time
again where can I get you pass no
problem that was unbelievable it's like
my own house that was unbeliever got a
shoe but do you think that that's gonna
kill her no there's my rule if
somebody's not gonna die we're all in
business here oh my god
I did was [ __ ] my daughter right so
how do you feel I'm exhausted I feel
great I mean they're out the door man
I'm good I feel like you just nailed it
like you blew that out of the park that
was thank you unbelievable Thanks do you
think that you might want to have a
daughter hell no no are you inspired no
no well regardless of whether or not you
want daughters that was brilliant
thank you it was beautiful thank you
that was beautiful parents like a raised
burial hustle into that so that's all I
got for today I'm Hannah your friendly
neighborhood wine mom special special
thanks to Caitlin for coming and being
such a good sport and just crushing that
challenge and if we want to see more of
you where can we find you you can find
me on the mick ah premier I can fight
let me do it for me again ah
you can watch the mick on Fox and it
premieres on January 1st I know I'll be
watching with bottle of wine not even a
glass on my jaw bottle just sounds hard
then you do like me okay so much do you
ever do that no but I just thought that
was like we were doing a special thing
for my show oh I'm just gonna be
drinking it alone that's just what you
did okay that's fine that's good
til next time
good work like a true mom just in case
there was anything left in broke Caitlyn
old it's okay and also I smelled it okay
[Music]